an effort by democrats to create new
federal laws for state
elections has hit a roadblock in their
own party
west virginia senator joe manchin
announced in a charleston newspaper that
he will
not support it that could sink the move
to override republican state laws that
limit
voting access wisha zhang is at the
white house wija what are the odds that
the president
can get mansion to change his mind
good morning anthony at this point it
looks like it is close to zero senator
manchin made clear in that op-ed
and in interviews that he is not opposed
to all of the substance of the bill
his biggest issue is that not a single
republican
has signed on board manchin wrote that i
believe that partisan voting legislation
will destroy the already weakening binds
of our democracy
and for that reason i will vote against
the for the people act
the bill would require states to offer
15 days of early voting
and no excuse absentee voting restrict
political gerrymandering and change
campaign finance laws among other things
some progressives were quick to
criticize manchin like new york
congressman mondaire jones
who tweeted manchin's op-ed might as
well be titled
why all vote to preserve jim crow
on face the nation mansion made his case
for why the gop would actually help
support a narrow bill even though we
have seen time and time again
republicans in several states push for
more
restrictive voter laws i can tell you
what goes around comes around it could
be more damaging to them too
the bottom line is the fundamental
purpose of
of our democracy is the freedom of our
elections
if we can't come to agreement on that
god help us john
manchin also repeated that he would not
vote to weaken
or get rid of the filibuster and that
may jeopardize several other items on
president biden's agenda
like police reform immigration reform
and gun control
gail all right misha thank you very much